Je vais regarder ces trucs en coulisses
ne soyez pas comme Chris J'ai repris mon souffle
et ferme ta bouche deux secondes de
conneries Je suis tellement privilégié d'être le
public J'ai une très longue poitrine
ici je pense  nous avons établi
qu'elle est toujours à la recherche là-
bas, c'est comme ça que Rocky a merdé Je
pense qu'il y a une excellente chimie entre
Bryce et Chris mais je pense que cela a évolué
jusqu'à un certain point et maintenant ils peuvent fondamentalement
trouver une nouvelle façon de se rapporter à chacun  autre
qui a autant de comédie que de
drame Chris disait, essayons de le
sentir comme si cela se produisait, que cela
se produise dans l'instant au lieu de trois le
déterminer ouais et elle a dit super
mais elle faisait semblant et elle
prédéterminait déjà hé toi  sais ce que je
vais faire
[Musique]
toi